the Nissan 370z is a sports coupe a to
make you drool probably the loveliest
version is the convertible the roadster
this sleek beast from Japan gives you
more bang for your buck than do
comparable European models in Germany
the convertible with its 241 kilowatt
3.7 liter naturally aspirated v6 engine
cost just over 40,000 euros the one we
took out for a spin has 6 gear manual
transmission and this on 370z is a power
cruiser thanks to the big 3.7 liter
engine you can accelerate from 40
kilometers an hour and 5th gear without
any shuddering or jolting you couldn't
do that with a smaller engine and city
traffic the 370 C is a gas guzzler 15
point 4 liters per hundred kilometers
the average for the combined cycle of
town and country driving is 10 point 6
liters for a convertible with a huge
engine that is not unusual it goes from
zero to a hundred and 5.3 seconds
maximum torque is 363 Newton meters
370z has this s mode button it does not
stand for sport mode but synchro
rev-match when you downshift the system
bleeps the throttle to achieve the ideal
engine rpm for the gear change which is
then much smoother than without double
clutching when it might lurch a little
there's no gospel - why is it doing this
nothing's okay at high speed approaching
250 kilometres an hour
it gets pretty loud even with the roof
up the Roadster really comes into its
own with the roof down out on a country
road the design is distinctive and
impressive now flowing organic lines
contrast with the sharp angles of the
lights the form of the 370z embodies
dynamism and sportiness
between the twin exhausts a rear fog
light underscores the sporty look
I think an important question for anyone
contemplating buying a convertible is
how long it takes to put up the roof
let's do the test that's quickly get
some hot see stopwatch is running that
sounds a bit rough
it could be a bit quieter missing a lot
of works something in customs
so just about 22 seconds by the way you
can only raise or lower the top when the
370z is stationary
canidates anyone familiar with the z
series will feel right at home in the
370z as in its ancestor the classical
240z the 370z also has these three
instruments on top of the dashboard oil
temperature gauge volt gauge ad clock
so to sum up then this on 370 C looks
great and the engine is great you can
put the top down when the weather is
good and it is cheaper than its
competitors and if you don't need a
convertible you can get the coupe a for
6000 euros less that is really quite a
bargain is cobbled a there are some
minor issues a lot of plastic in the
interior and a somewhat sticky gearshift
but they hardly detract from the charms
of this powerful beast
you